dancers dragons and a whole lot of death
This Is The Life of rhaenyra Targaryen
but where heavy spoilers for House of
the Dragon lie ahead born in 97 AC
princess rhaenyra is the firstborn child
of King viserys the first and queen Emma
rhaenyra's father inherits the throne in
time of turmoil the fifth King of the
Targaryen Dynasty is chosen to rule by
the great Council of 101 AC after the
Old King jahiris the first loses both of
his male heirs joharis convenes the
noble houses of Westeros to decide who
will inherit the crown as his successor
viserys is chosen over his cousin
rhaenis despite being the younger of the
two rhaenys are nicknamed the queen Who
Never Was discusses the great council's
decision with young rhaenyra in the
second episode of House of the Dragon
telling the princess man gonna put the
round to the torch
and see a woman Ascend the iron throat
but there is an Emma try multiple times
to conceive a male air throughout their
marriage resulting in several
miscarriages still bursts and ultimately
a brutal and bloody fate for Queen Emma
after a non-consensual medieval
C-section ends the Queen's life the
teenage rhaenyra is officially named for
saris's Heir this differs slightly from
Fire and Blood In the book of viserys
names rhaenyra his Heir when she is just
80 years old
King visery is the first defies
tradition and naming his daughter the
heir to the Iron Throne however the king
does a half-hearted job of securing
rhaenyra's position of power especially
after he has Sons by Alison's Hightower
rather than challenge male primogeniture
or make a formal Declaration of
Targaryen exceptionalism viserys
seemingly just hopes for the best
oblivious to the Civil War flaring up
around him House of the Dragon suggests
that viserys is motivated by a mixture
of guilt for Emma's death and a desire
to keep his hot-headed brother Damon
away from the throne does viserys love
his daughter yes but doesn't that mean
he should work harder to secure her
future as Queen probably
rhaenyra is beloved by the people of
Westeros during her youth so much so
that they dub her the Realms Delight in
honor of her esteemed Beauty as a child
she serves as a cup Bearer to her Father
which gives her access to all of his
Council meetings and first-hand
experience of the inner machinations of
governance rhaenyra's reputation
plummets over the course of her life
however Fire and Blood tells us the
Targaryen Queen became a controversial
figure in her later years earning some
very unsavory nicknames from the people
of Westeros young gray Nero is portrayed
by Millie olcock in House of the Dragon
while actor Emma Darcy later takes over
the role as an older version of the
character casting to actors to portray
Rainier might be more than a practical
decision on the showrunner's behalf by
seeing two versions of rhaenyra viewers
get to experience the distinct phases of
rhaenyra's life and see how her
experience in westerosu politics changes
her over time in one of the earliest
scenes in House of the Dragon rhaenyra
soars over King's Landing on the back of
her Dragon right Nero Rising Dragon
Cyrax nicknames the golden Beast for her
striking gold scales named after a
Valyrian goddess Cyrax is less
aggressive and battle worn than Prince
Damon's Dragon karaxi's the blood worm
nevertheless Cyrax is a force to be
reckoned with
there are power men should never have
trifled with
one abroad Valeria it's Doom rhaenyra
takes to the sky on Cyrax for the first
time at the tender age of seven unlike
other famous Targaryen dragons such as
Valerian the black dread Cyrax only has
one Rider throughout her life in Fire
and Blood rhaenyra's son Prince Joffrey
attempts to fly Cyrax only for the
dragon to reject her Rider and throw him
from her back to his death it's clear
from the opening of House of the dragon
that rhaenyra and Cyrax have a close
Bond but this is Westeros where happy
endings are few and far between Fire and
Blood hands down a terrible fate for
Cyrax who is killed by a rioting mob
that storms a dragon piss in defiance of
the targaryens
in the long and bloody history of
Westeros where Nero Targaryen is the
first woman to sit on the Iron Throne
she later has her Reign disputed and
discredited by her rival aegon II as
well as the maesters of the Citadel
who'd announce her as a usurper however
rhaenyra nevertheless sits on the throne
after her faction known as the blacks
takes King's Landing from aegon rhina
rules for six months in King's Landing
earning her the moniker the half-year
queen book law frames her as the only
woman to have ever sat on the throne
although in Game of Thrones Cersei
Lannister follows in rhaenyra's
footsteps and becomes a queen of
Westeros after the death of her children
in the season 6 finale despite her
discredited sovereignty rhaenyra remains
a powerful figure in the Targaryen
Dynasty and an influential ancestor for
Daenerys in the books the Mother of
Dragons is the second Sovereign Queen in
her family after rhaenyra as she rules
the city of mirin while lenger claimed
to the Iron Throne of Westeros the
similarities between rhaenyra and Cersei
honestar don't end there however the
Targaryen Queen has five children who
are key figures in the dance of the
Dragons her first three children jacaris
lucaris and Joffrey are born from
rhaenyra's Marriage to Sir Leno valarian
like Cersei however the legitimacy of
her children is doubted with the realm
speculating that the boys are actually
the son of rhaenerys's lover so how and
strong we know
father
everyone knows
just look at them rhaenyra later gives
birth to two more sons aegon and viserys
fathered by Prince Damon Targaryen
rhaenyra is pregnant with her sixth
child when her father viserys finally
dies the news triggers a difficult labor
and tragedy strikes twice for the
Targaryen queen as her daughter visenya
does not survive the birth
the first time rhaenyra Targaryen
marries it is for Duty the princess has
wed to Sir Leonor valarian in 114 AC but
makes no secret of her to Stace for him
Fire and Blood speculates that rhaenyra
was forced to marry Lenor by viserys who
threatened to denounce her as his Heir
if she didn't go through with the
marriage it is heavily suggested that
Leonor is gay and in love with sir
Joffrey lammuth with whom he spends most
of his time at high tide despite
spending most of her time a court away
from her husband rhaenyra becomes
friends with lenor's sister Lena
valorian who marries Damon Targaryen and
in the book dies giving birth to their
twin daughters when Lenor and Lena die
in 120 AC by Nero and Damon marry in
secret against the wishes of King
viserys their relationship is creepy
right from the start Damon gives his
niece various trinkets from his voyages
and courts her from a young age
my nearest Formal title Isaiah to King
viserys is Princess of Dragonstone a
title passed down to all Targaryen heirs
like her ancestor Daenerys Bears his
title at the beginning of Game of
Thrones Daenerys serves as heir to her
brother viserys as the only known
Targaryen left after Robert's Rebellion
after the deaths of viserys and The
Unborn son rhaego Daenerys assumes
sovereignty of House Targaryen believing
herself to be the last of the Dragon
Lords both Daenerys and rhaenyra's story
arcs are driven by prophecy in House of
the Dragon viserys tells his daughter
about a prophetic dream that aegon the
first once had a dream that motivated
the Conqueror to unify Westeros with
Fire and Blood they're gone so absolute
Darkness riding on those winds and
whatever dwells within will destroy the
world of the living
the princess of Dragonstone is heir to
her father's crown and her family's
responsibility in order to maintain
their responsibility rhaenyra spends a
great deal of time fending off Crown
hungry suitors from other noble families
such as House Lannister house Frey and
house Tyrell
King viserys makes Alison Hightower his
wife in 106 AC the daughter of viserys's
hand sir Otto Hightower Alison gives
birth to four children over the next few
years the coming of these children make
the realm anxious will Rainier remain
viserys's Heir or will patriarchal
Traditions Force the king to name Prince
aegon his eldest son the new heir to the
throne to the king's credit viserys does
not budge Rayner is the air through and
through but that doesn't stop the
targaryens from splintering into two
factions in Fire and Blood rhaenyra
makes a bold statement by dressing in
the traditional Targaryen colors to
symbolize her status as the future of
House Targaryen juxtaposing Alison's
green gown the two factions are
thereafter dubs the blacks and the
greens after the princess and the
Queen's costumes Alison and aegon lead
the greens with rhaenyra and Damon at
the head of their opposition aegan who
will become known as aegon II ryzer
dragon Sunfire while his brother Eamonn
one eye rides Vega the oldest largest
Targaryen dragon rhaenyra and aegon
never fight directly on their dragons
other characters fight and die on their
behalf a Civil War decimates House
Targaryen wiping out nearly all of the
dragons and triggering the steady
decline that leads to Robert's Rebellion
although she rules King's Landing for
only six months rhaenyra quickly becomes
an unpopular Queen the people initially
cheer for her when she takes her throne
from her brother but when rhaenyra hikes
taxes dramatically to fund the war it is
the people of King's Landing who pay the
price starving and oppressed the people
rebel against her led by a high
sparrow-like figure named The Shepherd
rioters take over the city storm the
dragon pit and kill a number of dragons
rhaenyra flees to Dragonstone but aegon
and his forces wait there in Ambush
aegon has had a tough time by this point
having been severely wounded multiple
times during the war after capturing
rhaenyra he sentences her to death by
Dragon Sunfire Burns and devours her all
while her son looks on it ate her while
her son watched
what's left of us buried in the Crips
right down there most of what we know
about rhaenyra and her family comes from
mushroom a dwarf who served as a court
jester to the targaryens mushroom is a
Tyrion Lannister archetype both share a
propensity for wine and body jokes for
example most importantly mushroom and
Tyrion are underestimated by the people
around them like Tyrion mushroom uses
this to his Advantage by becoming privy
to important information that the Nobles
don't bother to conceal from him
mushroom documented an account of the
dance of the Dragons titled the
testimony of mushroom his testimony
forms a backbone of Fire and Blood and
so narrator of the history book
arcmaster gildane does his best to
discern the truth from the lies mushroom
makes some pretty salacious claims in
his testimony too gildane Compares his
accounts of the events to other
historians like septon UTIs and Grand
maester muncan whose Tales often
contradict then again in Westeros any
Scandal is possible mushroom doesn't
appear in House of the Dragon though
co-creator Ryan Condell has confirmed
that there will at least be some nods to
the character
after Rainier was death it seems as if
aegon II has won the war but all is not
lost for the Queen's cause the blacks
continue to fight in her name with a new
Army of northmen and knights from the
vale approaching King's Landing Craig
and Stark leads his soldiers to the
capital where they discover that aegon
II has been poisoned the greens bend the
knee to Craigen who makes some severe
changes in the city on behalf of
rhaenira's son the Future King aegon III
craigan's Six-Day rule is dubbed the
hour of the wolf with it the dance of
the Dragons comes to an end aegon III is
crowned at the age of 11 though the
young king remains deeply traumatized by
the death of his mother and falls into a
lifelong depression it is drawing
aegon's Reign that the last of the
Targaryen dragons dies earning him the
nickname Dragon Bane and while rhaenyra
might not win the throne in the end her
Legacy lives on as her ancestry extends
all the way to Jon Snow and Daenerys
Targaryen The Last Scions of the House
of the Dragon
foreign
[Music]